hey there friends so in all of the
craziness of the year end wrapup for
2023 there was a thing that happened
that uh I didn't really talk about at
the time because I was so busy doing
other things but I now kind of recognize
was a little bit more important than I
realized and that is that at the age of
43 I for the first time was diagnosed
with ADHD uh with autism traits which
came as zero surprise to many of the
people around me um
but it also kind of came with some
answers to some long-standing questions
for me personally and I kind of wanted
to talk a little bit about both why it
took so long for me to get a diagnosis
as well as how that impacts my work with
flow arts and pois spinning and how I
think it impacts how other people
interact with the flow arts and po
spinning as well Drex here from Drex
Factor po sharing with you the love of
Po spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today we're
going to do a deep dive into brains but
before we dive in let me just give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pirate ha light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- buus friend
of the channel Becca Becken thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission all right so first
and foremost let's talk about ADHD and
more broadly about neurod Divergence um
ADHD is a disorder that is recognized
both in children as well as adults that
basically uh brings together a bunch of
individual symptoms everything from uh
risk-seeking to an inability to Focus uh
to sensory seeking and a variety of
other different symptoms and
characteristics uh it is kind of lumped
together with uh autism and dyslexia and
dyscalculia and a bunch of other
different conditions into a broad
umbrella that is uh known as
neurodivergence we're doing a terrible
job of describing this thus far and I
will leave a link to uh some resources
that better describe both the condition
as well as uh this overall umbrella
under which all of these conditions are
placed um the long and short of it is is
that you know there's a bunch of
different ways that human brains can uh
can can sometimes function a little bit
differently than then might be uh might
be ideal in a variety of different
circumstances and depending upon which
of those particular characteristics a
brain is exhibiting you might get stuck
in one of several different kind of
buckets within within that umbrella and
the funny thing is for me is that
looking back on it growing up it was
like painfully obvious that I had ADHD
but uh nobody really caught it for a
couple reasons the first of which was
that
um basically one of the theories as to
how ADHD works is that there's a deficit
of dopamine which means that when
somebody is seeking something to hold on
to their interest it is more difficult
for them than it is for other people and
so when indeed the dopamine does hit uh
all of the sudden they go into
hyperfocus mode and um I hope I
hyperfocused a lot when I was a little
kid a lot a lot like um such to the
point where um my teachers and the
librarian were really curious what was
going on there and at the same time um I
got to be pretty good at an early age at
something called masking that that is
presenting as not being neurod Divergent
uh presenting as being neurotypical um
such that I think a lot of people around
me just assumed that I was kind of a
quirky kid but didn't think much else in
the meantime somehow I would have this
ability to sit down and read through a
Michael kryon novel in a single sitting
but I could not do homework for the life
of me um again looking back on it really
painfully obvious but at the time people
were baffled by this they were like
multiple interventions between my
parents and my teachers trying to figure
out what was going on but again nobody
feel that ADHD is a possibility and you
know it's also got to be said that uh
the whole risk-taking thing is something
that also fits me like a glove after all
who was it who jumped in a with a car
full of belongings to move to the east
coast on a whim to find work in the
anti-genocide movement with $300 in his
bank account who quit a uh regular job
in order to pursue a career spinning
balls on strings and internet videos
back
before posting internet videos was a
career for
anybody um the risk-taking thing has
definitely been alive and well with me
as well as like seeking novelty you know
I've changed up the format of my channel
and my videos several times over the
years I'm always looking for ways to
improve I don't think that'll ever end
for me and now at least partially I have
an explanation as to why and of course
as I'm discussing this I would be remiss
if I didn't point out that what I do for
a living flow arts and po spinning I
think it probably has an enormous amount
of Peel not just to me but also to other
neurod Divergent people you know when it
comes to learning Po and another flow
Arts there's an enormous amount of
physical activity that's involved with
that it falls very very easily into the
world of stemming um and also too like
there's a constant novelty associated
with that I built bu my channel on the
idea of posting a new trick every single
week and I think a big part of why it
took off is that there was a big
audience for that Weekly new
novelty you know I I did a little bit of
research before putting together this
video and it's kind of funny because I
was looking for like nearest Neighbors
in terms of uh Industries in which there
was a high prevalence of neurod
Divergence and the two that I looked up
were uh turns out that surveys have
reviewed s that the prevalence of neurod
Divergence in the music industry is
anywhere between 30% in the more General
Industry and up to 58% just in the
electronic music industry alone which
given that the prevalence of neuro
divergency in the general population is
thought to be anywhere between 15 to 20%
of people my goodness like that is
anywhere from close to double to maybe
four times the background rate of neurod
Divergence that's
impressive more specifically in the
world of uh
ADHD uh there was a study by a
organization um children adults with uh
ADHD it's called Chad for short and uh
they were doing a study of college
athletes and just the acronym is so
obnoxiously appropriately named in this
case but they found that amongst College
athletes 7% of them were being medicated
for ADHD and uh you know given that the
background rate of that in the joural
population is something like 3 to
4% you know between uh between the music
industry and sports and I genuinely
think that PO and flow Arts are kind of
like sitting in an intersection between
these two things it absolutely makes
sense that PO and flow Arts would be
hugely appealing to people with ADHD and
who fit in into other categories of
neurod divergency as well uh my
girlfriend who is autistic actually
pointed out to me that she spots me
masking in a lot of my videos and so one
of the reasons that I decided to do this
off the cuff like this is cu I wanted to
experiment with being on camera and not
masking and just seeing what happened so
if you're watching out there hun let me
know how this went so granted there has
never been a study to my knowledge
looking for the prevalence of different
neurod
Divergent God damn it there's a train
coming okay the train is still passing
but I think that the engine at least as
far away now that it's not going to kill
the audio uh one of the more amusing
things that I came across as I was doing
a little bit of research for this video
is uh I didn't actually notice that uh
one of the things they recommend for
people with ADHD if they're having
problems focusing is to go out and do a
physical activity for like an hour and
it'll improve their focus and i' I've
been doing
that maybe my entire adult life it's one
of the reasons I really love pois
spinning is like if I'm having a tough
time focusing on a particular day it's
like okay go outside and spin for 30 40
60 minutes and uh it'll help me be able
to focus when I come back like uh yeah
there were there there were the the
answer was right in my face the whole
time so I don't know if anybody has
thought to go around and do a study
searching for the prevalence of neurod
Divergence amongst pois Spinners flow
artists and those adjacent to us uh I
kind of suspect the numbers are going to
be real high again um I have ADHD a lot
of the friends that I hang out with have
ADHD such to the point that like I
remember years ago uh having a
conversation with a couple with two of
my closest friends and kind of jokingly
saying to them that somebody had
suggested to me that I had the condition
and rather than them laughing at it as I
was expecting they both just kind of
stared at me and they're just like wait
that's a thing you didn't already know
about yourself but assuming that I'm
correct and the flow Arts are a thing
that is very attractive to neurod
Diversion people of all kinds of Stripes
I think that's kind of cool not just
because it creates some opportunities
like say if you are a teacher out there
and you happen to have a kid who's uh
struggling to focus in class hey maybe
giving them a set of Po to go spin for a
few minutes before they've got to sit
down and do their lesson what a concept
also too I think that it's kind of cool
that you know our culture is really
really not built to uh to be a good
container for neurod diversion people um
and I think there's a lot of reasons for
that but you know having this kind of
weird little pocket that I think can be
a home for us not just in that it
presents us with things that keep us
physically active as well as things that
you know kind of satisfy that desire
both for repetitive action I know for a
lot of autistic people they're trying to
work through uh prior perception and PO
is a great way to do that um but also
too just having a place where that's
kind of normal and we feel like we're
around other people like us is always
comforting and nice uh and of course you
know there's the novelty of uh you know
climbing up that trick ladder that's
something that nearly all of us get into
this looking for plus which in terms of
novelty and risk-taking I would be
remiss if I didn't point out that yeah
fire spinning how about that so for me
it's good to have an answer on this
score uh it's kind of good to know this
little piece of the puzzle for me and
have several years worth of History
explained for me um you know I think
that I'm still in the process of
figuring out the specifics of what all
that means to me um and how it impacts
my life even to this day but I'm hoping
too that kind of by talking about it it
also creates an opportunity for other
people to explore and talk about their
own version of this in their lives which
Speaking of if you are also a flow
artist who fits underneath the neurod
Divergent umbrella drop me a comment and
uh let me know uh what it is that uh
that you're working with and also too
how uh flow Arts fits into that scheme
for you is it something that you feel
helps ground you is it something that
gives you some novelty to play with
what's going on leave me a comment and
let me know and we have a helicopter
today too because of course we do and
now of course I'm remembering why I
sometimes avoid going outside to film
any who thanks for coming along on a
walk with me and listen to me chat about
all this uh I will include links to
resources and the sources for the stuff
that I'm talking about down in the
description if you want to check it out
for yourself this video would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I'd love to
give a shout out to my flow Patron who
are listed on screen right now um
without patreon it would be really
really difficult for me to produce
videos regularly uh patreon kind of save
my bacon in that regard so if you'd like
to see more videos and more high quality
videos and perhaps stuff that's more
scripted than this just off the cuff
stuff that I was doing today um I'd
highly recommend signing up to support
me over on patreon you can do that at
patreon.com dfactor poo um every little
bit helps uh this is my full-time gig
and I really appreciate getting to do
that and uh the support on patreon means
I get to focus more on making videos
than on doing thing other things that
bring money in the front door so help me
out there and I'll help you out it's
great it's a great deal and if you dug
this video on ADHD and uh neur
Divergence in the flow Arts uh I you
might also like some of the other videos
that I have done on various aspects of
mental health and the flow Arts
including my own struggles with
depression I will go ahead and uh link
to a playlist of videos I've done on
those topics down in the description as
well as up on screen um thank you so
much for watching make sure to get out
and Flo day yourselves and I will see
you with a new video real soon take care
now peace